[Music]
my favorite time of the year is coming
up my fa i think it's my favorite
holiday is halloween i love halloween i
don't really dress up anymore but um
well you are in your 40s
i decided like it's a weird thing
we grew up really loving laurel and
hardy and the marx brothers and like old
fashioned comedy uh charlie chaplin
so we decided to dress up as the marx
brothers for one halloween until i found
out that i had to be
chico marks our older brother damian got
to be groucho you know everyone knows
groucho fun christian the cigar the yeah
yeah the glasses the lines yeah and
harpo you got to have like i got my
hands on that roll you know harp was fun
because you get the especially for you
you were the youngest you were probably
the quietest of the three of us
definitely chico what do you do with
cheating what do you do especially if
you can't do an italian accent which i'm
not even gonna still i still can't
really do uh so i was really i just
remember being like i can't believe in
our i couldn't say my ours either well i
think you should be thankful in
retrospect that we didn't make you be
zeppo
that's very what do you do with zeppelin
that's true i should have looked at it i
mean look in the bright side
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
welcome to life is short i'm your host
justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always is my brother
harpo hey
christian sorry
long um
i wonder if they i had heard somewhere
that harpo i think we talked about in
the show that groucho was supposed to be
kind of a tough and surly and
grouchy i mean harpo was supposed to be
like he was sweet apparently yeah and
apparently also uh zeppo i just made fun
of him but
i've heard that he was like
the most talented he was really really
handsome too very handsome and yeah i
think i heard that too that he was
really talented really smart baby was
well oh no no this is what it was he
ended up being the most successful of
them because he ran he started some
other business we got to google this uh
but zeppo ended up having like a really
nice
life i think uh or or did he have like
sex parties and stuff with his wife i
well that's not not a nice life
that's true that's true
the point of us talking about uh being
the marx brothers in addition to
highlighting what a spoiled uh cynical
kid i was you were so upset i was i
remember you
really crying you were really yeah
that's embarrassing you were what 17 18
[Laughter]
you were really upset i have a [ __ ]
picture of you i think just post-crime
tantrum and it's the three of us i've
got my trench coat on and damian's got
his mustache and glasses and you're like
kind of like splotchy like post crying
with your like little chico hat in your
plaid shirt it's really funny i gotta
find that picture i had a wig i had a
curly wig and and my dad i remember pod
trying to be like you know chico talks
like
now chica would be really fun to do
paw's what we call her father daddy grow
up on a little house in the prairie yeah
we didn't live on a farm well the reason
we're blathering on about the marx
brothers yeah uh our guest today reminds
me it reminds you reminds both of us you
don't both have to be reminded of this
uh of
one of these one of these people were
talking like the marx brothers laurel
and hardy chaplin a classic comedic like
a real throwback yeah like a brilliant
um comedic force yeah uh our guest is
tony hale and tony's got um the timing
of that kind of brilliant marx brothers
timing
uh and he's got this great physical
component to his comedy and i think he
actually just physically he resembles
buster keaton he does in a in a very
like
clear way i think he's in a very um
obvious way i would say he looks if they
did a biopic about buster keaton i would
i would love for tom tony should play
he's also a great actor i mean he's he's
got he's got it all he's one of the
nicest people too he and julie louis
dreyfus on veep that their connection
their that combination is
to me
we talk about this you talk about this
in the interview yeah it it is
reminiscent of
chico and harpo or laurel and hardy or
yeah it's you know uh i think it'll last
abbott and costello totally it's it's
they're they're like great dance
partners you know they're like ginger
rogers yeah
you know
like yeah lucille ball and and dez yarn
ass they're they're
they move so well together they're
they're they're so symbiotic their their
comedy um as a duo they're just as a
incredible duo but tony's great in
everything and i've worked with tony in
a more dramatic capacity uh and i've
seen him work i mean i've sat across
from him while he acts and
he's just so grounded and real he never
even when he's doing wacky stuff
he did one of the alvin the chipmunks
movies and he's still
so grounded in that in a role like that
you know yeah god he is such a nice
person he really is for those who don't
watch veep he
was equally brilliant on arrested
development
yeah yeah he was playing a character so
similar to the character from veep but
um
even more extremely uh needy and
uh insecure and tony explores different
shades of anxiety with both of those
characters that's a good way of putting
it um
and
christian and i
when we but i also remember when we
talked to tony uh we had yet to see toy
story 4. i was going to say that uh-huh
it was before you both have to think
that you should say well we hadn't seen
it because it wasn't out yet it was like
a week before it came out i think uh but
we've since seen it you've seen it right
i've seen it yeah got it we saw it
together we did oh on the plane oh no in
the theater yeah we did yeah together
together
sorry it was a memorable experience
uh he was i don't get why dates why
people go to movies i mean movies are
great i love movies but why you would go
not that not to compare what we did to a
date but i was just thinking like
think about that like you don't get to
really know the person i guess the best
thing is to go to a movie and then
dinner counterpoint it's a shared
experience even though you're doing it
in silence that's what i was you're
doing something together that's true
anyway he is amazing in toy story 4.
he's so good and that movie is so good
anyway so if
you've probably all seen toy story 4 at
this point if you haven't you should
check it out if you haven't it's about
to get a pretty big box office pump
your welcome dream works
and if you you you've not heard tony on
uh on one of us he's also great on
interviews he's great on talk shows he's
just great he's great here we go uh my
interview with the sweet kind hilarious
tony hale
life could be a dream sweetheart
do you have puppies i have two puppies
do you really mm-hmm are you watching
francis
and i used to be allergic to animals i
never really liked dogs because of it
and then i got two dogs and now i'm
crazy about dogs why'd you get the dogs
if you were allergic they're
hypoallergenic
they're like shades they're hairless
what do they look like they're like
they're super
they're so cute but i think like some
hypoallergenic dogs i did have a bit of
a reaction to so i kind of just played
like my friends had this type of dog so
i kind of just would hang around and i
didn't have a reaction what does it it
means it's hair it's hair instead of fur
is that what it is our parents lied to
us about one of our one of the three
boys one of us was allergic i think and
i think to take some of the pressure off
that one she said we were all allergic
to dogs so i spent and this is something
i didn't learn until i was like in my
20s by the way i had just the opposite
experience my parents knew i was
allergic and they were like let's just
keep getting dogs
and then grow out of it and then i just
had asthma attack after asthma just like
going and then we then that dog would
die and i'd be like oh thank god get
another dog
and i just made you take up smoking i
was just attached to inhaler my entire
childhood and it's because of that and
and
as was that was always a scary thing
when you did you ever do that when you
inhaled did you have asthma or do you
have asthma i do still i still have it
occasionally i still use my inhaler
every now and then yeah yeah me too bro
oh my god yeah my drug of choice welcome
to the nerdist oh there already is a
nerdist uh we'll think of another name
uh but i i once
this is this is a dope story i once
inhaled uh without taking the lid off
sure oh yes i thought it was gonna die
well also you're when you're when all
you want to do is breathe you're not
thinking of the small things like taking
the lid off yeah and then it gets stuck
in your windpipe
i'm funny i once went to the emergency
room when i was a kid couldn't breathe
and
somehow the i don't know if it was an
intern giving me a shot or whatever but
they gave me a shot and something broke
in my arm
like something hit something in the
needle something the needle broke off
something happened but i didn't even
feel it because i was just like just i
can't breathe like i didn't care but
some some kind of like that's why you
were having an attack i was having
attacks they give you this like shot
yeah like a steroid yeah yeah and some
something uh i just i remember some kind
of story they pulled the needle out and
then part of it wasn't there
but i didn't care i was just like i can
breathe did they eventually get it out
i guess or it's still in me that's true
when you're scratching up my organs
that's true when you can't breathe
nothing else matters
it's like you're breathing through a
very small straw you're from virginia uh
tallahassee florida which is very
georgia it's close to virginia yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what i meant you're
near you grew up near virginia you guys
do your research on this podcast sorry
no that actually did before
um you sorry oh it's cause you went to
graduate school in virginia a little bit
when i think tony hill i just think
virginia you're you're you're you yeah
it's for lovers and tony hale it is for
lovers um
oh wait i want to start at the beginning
i want to start properly by the way i
like the title of your podcast life is
short oh thanks because i think it's
something we forget and it's a good
reminder to always hear it
and we're all going to die i just and
the stuff that i'm giving power to does
not matter most of the time that's it
that's why i and and also i like the pun
part that's funny sure uh it's good to
put on a poster a distant second but
yeah thank you i because you know it's
harder than you'd imagine to name
something like that sure because this is
all of you putting yourself out there
and conversing and you want to have the
right tagline to encapsulate that and
that's probably difficult here i am
world yeah that's what we always want to
say
every morning inside and out
um uh we've known each other for a long
time we that's no secret
that's a well-known world uh we worked
on that one indie movie together well
and then i go
yeah but but way before then we were
both cast uh
you ended up keeping your job on this in
this movie that's right um
i was fired from a movie called tale of
despero
and
but i so i met you on that i think we we
recorded some stuff together i was
actually thinking about that this
morning on the way here and then i i was
then i remember thinking okay if i get
asked was i ever fired
and i was because i was talking to
somebody about it recently it was an
animated show called
i think bubble guppies
okay and
i
i i just started doing animation and i
they just they didn't want me back and i
was like
but then i was commenting you had
recorded a couple i think i had recorded
the pilot and i just wasn't the right
voice and uh-huh and so i totally i mean
i get it but in the moment it's not a
good feeling at all yeah it was uh awful
it was i thought that was it i sure of
course of course and i and it was like a
dream job as you recall like we got to
work with some yeah really incredible
actors dustin hoffman wait was he in the
room when we were he
he i don't know if you were there for
this but we did a table read of it
didn't we yes yes he was there for that
no no he wasn't i don't think who was
there was you me it's tony uh no stanley
tucci yeah um god so many because they
gave mike's they put lav mics on us yeah
so it was different than most animated
movies which is you know you're in a
booth and uh you rarely see the other
actor you're reporting with right in
this case yeah we had these body mics
they boom they had mics all around us
and we were interacting in person
right but but you did the whole thing
and how how long was that and what was
that like i was just go figure the
quirky sidekick bro
well it worked you kept your job
someone must have worked quote checked
out
i think that's been every description of
every character
we're looking for a checked out tony
hale type yeah exactly
um and then but it was as you know like
these animation things you're
you i mean they're so fun to do but
you're not there
i mean
the truth is
the voice actors get the attention we
are such a small slice of the pie yeah i
mean these animators and producer i mean
the writer when they do so much crazy
work
on these movies and then the voice
actors we come in and we act crazy in a
booth and it's so fun yeah sure but it
is a very small slice of the pie it's
true and that i think that's the case
even with a lot with live action stuff
as well but not not nearly so much as it
is with uh i mean
you're there i mean
barely any time i never got actors who
you know i sometimes see people put
actors post things on
social media where they're they they go
on about
what the show the play they've done or
the you know this was the most
meaningful and like what we did out
there will forever change lives and i
i've just never felt that way about it i
i not not to say that it can't bring
it's not important and to bring joy to
people and to bring but i've never kind
of assigned that level of profound
importance on and uh what i do how do
how do you feel about what you do your
place in the world um oh
i know that's a light we start life
short let's get into it run out of time
we're closer now
this is why i think that's a great
question because i struggle with it i
struggle with
hmm if i'm really honest
it's
with everything going in the world
sometimes you're just like god i'm an
actor what kind of
what kind of impact are you making in
the world and
i think in terms of the work i mean yeah
sure i think it does make people laugh
and bring joy i probably
i get a lot of value out of
hopefully being um
a kind person enter like
with the relationships around like just
being on set and i love to
create those relationships and
um
just maybe hopefully be
an encouraging presence to somebody who
might need it you know it's like it's
those kind of smaller things i typically
give me walking away typically giving me
more value than maybe necessarily the
work well it's interesting you say that
because that makes sense it absolutely
does i think we i i try to do the same
thing and i i value that and i value
that about you i i
i mean i'm a huge work in progress but
like that's
definitely a goal of mine you're truly
one of the
nicest easiest people to be around and
fun i mean that's why i really enjoy
working with you but i also enjoy
um
whenever we do we've also been on this
sort of
game i don't know how else to say it
we've done a lot of game shows together
yeah that's right you're very fun
there's no one i'd rather play these
games with and there's always like a
little a little bit of um that's right i
forgot about that 25 000 pyramid that's
one oh we did them all and then uh what
else we did with the match game oh we
didn't yeah we might i think we well and
i didn't match it but it was i know
there was another one but we will do
manchester united okay um so there's
just like superficially i'm like oh good
if tony's doing this
i feel a little i feel better i feel
like les if there is any shame involved
in like
doing games on on tv which there there
shouldn't be but or maybe you should be
um well i think it's kind of any kind of
a hierarchy that's there's always some
kind of weird hierarchy out there and
we're always yeah we're always kind of
comparing ourselves to that what we
think is that hierarchy yeah it's still
high it's also like still high school
everything is guys so dc
hollywood everything yeah um which would
make
gosling like the captain of the football
team i guess but um fully yeah that
would make me the guy who's who are you
picked last yeah
me i'm i mean i thought that was me but
i'm i'm the guy he's got the asthma
on him that's right
um so you just like doing those games
i do i think they're really fun yeah
however as i'm this is that
my train of thought but when you were
saying before about kind of finding
value in the work i will say
recently okay years ago i did this
children's book and archibald archibald
and i
loved it it was a great experience i did
it with my friends tony by agni and
victor hud could be a great experience
it kind of came and went and then i did
this book it talked a lot about we can
talk about this later but i talked about
how i just wasn't present for most of my
life and i was always looking at the
next thing and missing where i was and
it's about this little chicken in march
about so anyways it became a cartoon
that is gonna be coming up on netflix
and i will say having worked on
something that
i just because this chicken walks into a
situation he's fully there uh he sees
the best in people he sees the best in a
situation
he's just joyful and kind and it's like
working on something that i just love
yeah there is it really because as an
actor you can when you're doing someone
else's work you love it but you don't
have the same investment that the person
sure created there's not a sense of
propriety right that's an uglier word
but but yeah it's not right living in
you exactly so this show i really do it
is exciting
as a contribution to put something
especially in today's times when yeah
just people are seeing the worst in
everybody of course this little chicken
named archibald with a wool sweater and
you know denim pants like seeing the
best in everybody it is it does give me
a lot of joy putting that in i bet
that's different yeah this is something
that is and also has meaning to you it's
it's it's pushing of something that's so
important now uh yeah and for kids too i
mean that they start uh
to combat whatever they're being exposed
to which i can't imagine be
growing up during this time yeah and
we've set the cartoon before social
media so it's kind of in the 80s
how does he struggle with being present
without so you know when i think of
problems with being present but the
first thing i think of is social media
oh about our phones now you see people
walking around like zombies i love new
york of course well my whole story with
that is because when i booked arrested
development it was my dream and it
didn't satisfy me the way i thought it
was going to satisfy yeah and it really
freaked me out
and it was and it was that whole thing
that i was i gave it so much weight that
dream
and all the years up to that i was
always looking at that big thing and the
thing is if you're not practicing
content where you are you're not going
to be content when you get what you want
absolutely and i just had not been
practicing being present so it really
scared me pretty bad and then i had my
daughter after arrested development and
one thing children force you to do is
they force you to be present because you
have to keep them alive like i was just
like and i really woke me up like i just
hadn't been that way
so archibald kind of came out of that
but in this so in this book he kind of
learns about being present in the series
he makes a lot of mistakes
but there's always the way his attitude
towards the mistakes is
just
not my attitude typically towards
mistakes
which is what which is just he just goes
with it i i aspire to that and how do
you deal with mistakes i mean i i hold
on to things
of course and anybody who i have a hard
time when people are just like oh you
know just let it go and i know i think
about like leave the audition don't
think i'm not that guy i know i i know
in theory that that's what you should do
yeah of course and i have i mean you can
attest this too for your own self you do
get better at it i do get better because
i do see a bigger picture of typically
it has nothing to do with your work it
typically has something else to do with
it
but it is tough i mean and i don't
forget about it yeah i mean i am i'm
still calling my agent saying i'm just
curious about that audition i had two
weeks ago did that ever you know it's
like and i am still curious about it and
you got into this relatively at at a
relatively older age right yeah i get
because i got arrested well i did
commercials in
new york for a long time and then
when i was 32 is when i booked arrested
development so that was definitely my
first big job and i've never been on the
studio a lot wow i've never had that
amount of free food yeah like i was just
like
oh it's the best that to me that hasn't
diminished no and it's still exciting
and i still don't understand that i
don't have to pay for lunch yeah like it
still baffles me yeah yeah but the thing
is this is what's so cool about getting
older is when i was younger
anyways but it's just like everybody
deals like if i saw if i saw other
people getting all these gigs
you that jealousy and that
um comparison all this kind of stuff
that can overtake you yeah and then the
older it's nice to get to a place and
i'm still it's a daily practice but like
when somebody
when they look in the news or i see all
these gigs or i see whatever
if i have jealous feelings it doesn't
make me a jealous person it's just
feelings
it's feelings that come and go
of course you process it it's all
like watching cars on the highway it's
just like oh yeah there's that thought
there's that feeling that doesn't i
don't know and where it used to be like
oh my god i'm an awful person how why am
i so i like that you know do you ever
feel that way about people you like yeah
i like them as a person and yet
well i should be happy that they got
this thing i know but you said you still
do like that person yeah yeah but it's
just a feeling and a thought that comes
that you just don't give power to yeah
it doesn't identify who you are and i
think that's been a really nice tool of
getting older in this business and like
you said having kids i'm sure really
helps yeah because then because oh like
these other these aren't problems these
aren't real problems yeah but giving
them giving validating them like i've
you know with my daughter i'm you can
kind of sometimes live in the what if
you're like oh god what if this happens
and it's like i'm powerless to that and
it's just a fleeting thought feeling
feeling and just stay present with her
you know it's that kind of reminder
something that helped me too was working
with with people who were
wildly successful and i'm sure you have
sure and and you see
how unhappy they they really are i mean
you you so when you talked about
once you started
having success and getting the parts
that you and it not bringing you
contempt i mean weren't content you
weren't happy well it was that it is
that
was my dream and it and it was like oh
no i thought this was gonna be different
yeah i don't know if i can speak into
somebody's if they i don't know if about
happy but i what i can speak into is you
do see a pattern of it's never enough
yes yes oh my god and it's that it's
that sense of my god it is never it
never caps yeah it's always enough and
then the challenge is for myself because
this is something we all struggle with
yeah we don't want to get to the end of
our lives and be like all i did was it
was never enough and now it's over and i
talk about this so much because i suck
at it i mean it's something i have to
keep talking about it just as a reminder
that's why i call the show life is short
i need those i want to remind myself of
that i i shot a movie once we did a
couple days at the hollywood forever
cemetery and i remember being released
oh yeah it was beautiful i mean it was
really fun to be there and also sort of
like is this sacrilegious is this like
are we you know they're like walking
over tombstones and stuff like they're
dead bodies yeah literally yeah well
they like show movies over there yeah
yeah yeah so i think they're pretty
liberal yeah um
but i remember having um really being
struck by this
thought
it was like the great equalizer right
like everybody had
the same had um could be reduced to the
same thing which is two numbers which
was a dash between two numbers
and i couldn't get that sometimes it
still hits me that like yeah it is a
reminder to
really not not take these these things
so to heart you know and that is a oh i
love that picture of shooting something
on the graveyard because i've talked
there's a story once i was working with
this producer
and keep in mind as i say this i know
i've had these moments i'm a work in
progress whatever but he was he was
being kind of an [ __ ] yeah
and there was that part of me that
wanted to walk up to him and kind of i
remember thinking about a graveyard we
were saying and being like you know
we're all going to go there and your
legacy yeah is that you are a dick
you're a turd and if you want that to be
your legacy yeah keep going the way
you're going but you have the choice to
make to be different right you can start
being kind that doesn't have to be your
legacy because it is fleeting people 56
years ago thought they were the [ __ ] i
know they're dead isn't that crazy
they're gone that's like in the you know
when you go to these award shows which
i'm so grateful to be at but those in
memoriams come up and you're like yeah
oh yeah wake up call guys we're all
going there ideally i'll get to be there
yeah ideally a flash on the screen
exactly and i'm actually doing a um a
play
in um january in san francisco called
wakey wakey and um one of the lines is
um a hundred thousand people died today
a hundred thousand people died yesterday
and a hundred thousand diet people died
three days ago
so there's been a hundred thousand
people who've been dead for three days
you know it's yeah but it's like each
day a hundred thousand
people you know and it's
we just forget that yeah anyways life is
short
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
we'll meet again
you were born in west point your dad was
in the yeah yeah yeah so do you do you
consider the term army brat pejorative
um first of all i'm always impressed
anybody uses a vocabulary word that i
don't often use right no
[Music]
rat
oh i love it now who's the brat you are
they're quick you're quick justin you
really are um and actually i was
probably a bit of a brat so it probably
worked out i don't really remember sixth
grade down much oh really yeah nor do i
i have terrible number do you have you
have a really bad memory and i don't
know if it's because i wasn't present
for most of my life uh-huh um but i just
sixth grade down is a real blur but we
also move like seven times before the
seventh grade right you so you
d did you get into theater did you get
into acting as a co i got into theater
well
um
were you coping yeah like as a way to
deal with it probably yeah making new
friends and totally well i moved to
tallahassee florida when i was in the
seventh grade because my dad retired
from virginia
from my many lovers
um but i um i uh so in the seventh grade
i moved to
tallahassee my dad retired as a colonel
and then he started working for the
state and that was and i was not into
sports
really
i know shocking
shocking
and i will never guess this but nor was
i
well i mean i could see you probably
playing soccer or something like that i
did i when i was a kid you didn't play
with like little league
well my dad there's a couple stories one
being he was coaching the soccer team
and i was the kid just building a dirt
pile sand castle on the ground
and then there there's this other time i
was well sure he must have been very
athletic he was like he was yeah he was
a colonel but his his dad was an opera
singer so he had an appreciation for the
arts oh okay but there's another time he
was watching me on the swim team and
everybody was swimming and he said i
just stopped while everybody because
there's those pools where you can just
stand up and everybody was swimming like
next to me and he had this look at me
like what are you doing and he said i
just said i'm exhausted why would i
why would i keep going
and so i
it just wasn't my forte
and then i i'm sure there was me you
know some asthma related there somewhere
but i was and then they kind of didn't
know what to do with me because i was a
bit of a spas so i was a bit of a brat
you're like well if you want you want
that dog if that dog is so important to
you i'm gonna stop it's not it's not
um and so i um
they found this theater called young
actress theater in tallahassee florida
and it was just a gift it was like it
was a place
because in the in the
because i was in the south keep in mind
and sports was like a religion yeah and
so it was tough to find florida state
florida state yeah and it was tough to
find friends and so they found this
theater and it was just a gift from god
it really was and that was around
seventh eighth eighth grade seventh
eighth grade and then i stayed in it
through high school oh okay so that's
nice that you had uh yeah and and so did
you go to you didn't go to college for
acting though no i went to college for
journalism that's right and and then i
and i
uh had a great experience at samford
university in birmingham alabama
studied
yeah
yeah
i went exactly i went to um hovard yeah
um but so your ambition was then to be
it's that it's i guess i mean i it
wasn't like a passion what i do remember
no no no
um oh you mean theater in journalism oh
journalism no no it was just to go i
think i was afraid to study theater i
think i can make a career out of it
i never really thought about what i was
going to do much
until probably my senior in college and
i was like oh i better start thinking so
then you went to grad school for now
then i went to then after after college
i said
um i kind of was at home for a little
bit and then i was like you know what
i'm just going to try this theater thing
and there was the school in uh virginia
and i thought i'd dip my toe back in
there yeah just to get to virginia
i knew it would get to my mini virginia
um but then i kind of dip my toe back
into acting and then in 95 i just moved
to new york and i said i didn't know
anybody and i was like i was like
um
uh i was freaked out yeah i'm bad but i
my first show was shakespeare in the
parking lot
which is yeah tammy the shrew in the
east in a parking lot east village oh
yeah i remember they they did that for a
while yeah yeah and i was 25 and i was
just so overwhelmed but i had you had
that young energy i was just like do
whatever yeah had so many odd jobs tempt
and cater with i loved cater waitering
it was i hated waiting tables oh
waiting tables at that caterpillar
waiting it's the same food
you um don't have to talk to the people
and you eat this great food at the end
of the night they give you 20 bucks an
hour and it was just they have to pay
for five hours so you would always make
100 bucks great and at night so you
could audition yeah and at night it was
very flexible you could call and just
say i'm available this time and then
temping i could never commit to like a
three or four day gig so i would always
show up at the temp office
the morning each morning and hoping they
would send me out to like should it be a
warm body to desk or someone who's sick
and then and then the great thing is i
would i would always make these all
these long distance phone calls
while sitting there because nobody knew
my family because back then you had to
yeah yeah yeah
i remember i remember
and then i would make all these long
distance phone calls but in the morning
when i was sitting in this temp office
i'll distinctly remember they only
played jim carrey movies in the lobby
all righty then it was just like the
mask and all this kind of stuff and it
was bright purple scissors are good
movies i mean you did yeah like they
they didn't play holly shores
and it was like this big kind of waiting
room and then they'd send us out and
just sit there and i remember where i
worked at vogue i was like when people
and i i worked at like
like st trading like devil wears prada
yeah
and when i watched that movie i remember
in that movie they say the clicking of
heels yeah i remember that yeah and i
remember sitting there and feeling
so out of place i just looked like a bad
gap like i just looked awful khakis
like yeah totally like a full like
fraternity like just southern kind of
ridiculousness i think i even saw anna
wintour down the hall and everybody you
know she was just the queen i i went to
the met ball uh and uh yeah oh man okay
now we gotta get into it when did you go
i i go every year no no no i i went what
did you wear this year um
dwight the first time i went was with
anna wintour's daughter b who's the
nicest just like we got to get in it's
just time to get into it so a friend of
mine was like b is looking for a fella
to go squire her to this thing and i was
like absolutely not and i then i met b
and she was so yeah sweet so lovely what
year was this this was
maybe six seven years ago eight years
ago and then when you have to work did
you like it wear a very fancy i wore a
um remember the thing bjork wore the
swan oh you were the she let me borrow
it yeah yeah yeah well i was at her
place and i needed something that was
the next day
no sh i was just like a tux you know
from some some fancy okay yeah i forget
uh what was it like uh it was because
i've heard it's not there's nothing
comfortable about it well at one point i
should preface this by saying at one
point i i i was given kalonapin i got on
this drug kalonapan in to deal with
social anxiety yeah sure sure sure and
it was mostly just i would only really
take it uh at like hollywood yeah an
event like yeah yeah and um
so that's that was my mindset and i had
stopped taking it um by the time i went
to this thing so i was and that kind of
knocks you out doesn't it because xanax
kind of chills you out right yeah it
would make me tired and uh but it helped
it really helped kind of i shouldn't
promote it are they one of our sponsors
kalaniman um did you take that when you
were on stage did when you did no no no
no no no and you know there's been times
where i've been tempted to take beta
block i have a friend who tried to sell
me on beta blockers uh can it lowers
your heartbeat i know a couple people
who swear by it yeah
one of one takes it for the talk shows
which which i might always get really
nervous you're very good at talk shows
uh you get nervous speaking of anxiety i
remember when i was doing conan years
ago
a few years back and i when i was i used
to have really bad panic attacks
and um i
this is probably about
eight years ago but anyways i was
right before the curtain opens you know
when you walk out i remember having this
wave of dread like a panic attack was
coming on and i was like oh [ __ ] this is
that crossroads where you either keep
going or you bolt yeah stomach do you
get your stomach i get it more chest
the chest yeah and um i'll never forget
there was two guys about to open the
curtains and i just started asking them
questions
i was just like i was like where are you
from oh my gosh and i remember saying
because you're you're trying to be
casual well casual but also get your
mind off yourself yeah because you're
just so obsessed in your head and so i
remember saying to them when did you go
i'm going would it be cool if somebody
did a documentary of like back here
like what people
what people are going through and
they're so and these guys are like why
are you two
yeah i mean they were nice but i'm just
like i'm just like drilling them with
questions just to get my eyes off myself
and then and then i remember and then
like a couple of the years after that i
was on conan and i remember leaving
oh that you'll love this and i i didn't
think it might i mean you know you
always have to have these stories and i
didn't know if my story was very good or
whatever and i remember going up to andy
richter and saying andy i just think
that just kind of was was nothing and he
goes tony it doesn't matter
and then he gave the example like it's
like you put a paper boat in the ocean
it's just
nothing
it just goes away i love him it's also
like you're there was probably a part of
you that was if you're as much like me
as i think you are there there may have
been a part of you that was looking for
some positive reasons but it's not even
that i mean what he does
no totally well not that we don't always
fish but i um i told him and to this day
i tell him all the time because i keep
thinking about it it was such a gift
because
what could be seen is like dude what do
you mean
it doesn't and it was such a comfort
because i'm giving something to power
that doesn't matter it's true i i i i
don't know that i've ever entirely
learned that lesson but uh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i've taken you off your path no no
there was something that you had said
that i wanted to go back to um
let me just finish the title i go to the
top of the i yes yes yes so i get to the
top of the stairs you have to send this
huge staircase and those staircases
because there's a there's also a big
staircase inside i assume it i assume
the photographers and stuff are from
outside outside yeah it's covered
because i think they cover it sure yeah
yeah just so like you know
civilians don't like him god forbid yeah
um but i so i'm and it is [ __ ] fancy
and everyone and their mother's there
and yeah
and i get to the top and i had been told
that i was going to uh i was with my
friend max and garrett and and i they
said you know i said well what do you
i've been told that anna wintour is at
the top um of the stairs and she's she's
in a greeting line you have to like
greet a bunch of okay like the queen
yeah it is um and
and i said uh oh well how do you agree
and and somebody had told me i somehow
had this in my head that i hope somebody
said curtsy just to really throw you off
[Laughter]
high five
she insists on a high on a big a very
aggressive high five i no i i had in my
head that i had to like kiss her on the
cheek oh amazing and so when i got her
with her daughter right well no i was
gonna meet her inside okay yeah uh and
it was just uh
my two friends and uh
and so i get to the top and i see
somebody kiss i think the guy in front
of me my friend kissed her and she
received it and was fine and i so i was
like oh okay this is definitely what you
do and i
went to kiss her on the cheek and as
she as i did this she extended her hand
and i took her hand
uh and shook her hand but i was couldn't
stop from my commitment to kissing her
on the cheek so i kind of like did a
weird like kind of pulled her in a
little bit as i kissed her around the
chair and as i'm leaning into this all
happened so quickly obviously but
as i lean in to kiss her i could see her
recoil oh okay and so i i talked about
like you know i could have stopped i
could have just i followed her
i followed her face
and i but i knew at this point that she
didn't want my kiss on her cheek so i
just kind of like like kissed the air
near her
and actually gave me the stretch
that's what they do in fashion that's
true
that is true it was um one of the
weirdest
greetings did she know that you were
with her i don't know at that point i
later on i had another then she were
called again when she saw you yeah that
was the guy that kissed near me gosh i
had this experience recently this
uh and you obsess about this thing that
i was with this i was at this premiere
and it was lovely and there was a friend
of mine who's very i wouldn't say a
friend we're more we
we're more of acquaintances but we see
each other every now and then and and
she's a big name
and she was making the joke that she was
um tired and wanted to take a nap on the
floor
because it was just a long day and i
started to
remove my coat
as a joke of like giving her a pillow
but then in my head
yeah in my mind i was thinking oh god i
hope she doesn't think that i was
removing my coat to make it look like
i'll take a nap
on that alongside you yes and it's like
all you think about
like why did you do that you're playing
a fork and a spork a spork a spork who's
called forkey okay and he's conflicted
because part of he doesn't know really
who he is right he's a bit he's having a
bit of existential crisis um he's not he
doesn't they think he's a he is a toy
this is in the new lars montreal this is
um this isn't toy story four it's gonna
be maybe it might be a little too edgy
for sundance yeah um but it's we're
gonna um anyway so he's kind of he
doesn't he doesn't want to be a toy
and uh he
but he this relationship in this
journey he goes on with woody he just
learns about
you know the value of being loved and
it's really really beautiful it's it's
um something that i'm
you're gonna love watching but also you
have a daughter who's about third yeah
who's not seen any of my work because
it's really it's too edgy
she's never seen beep no kidding we're
just she's a teenager she's 13. she's at
the age now where we'll probably start
watching if she wants to i mean she's
not really into watching
what i do yeah you know we we both did
alvin and chipmunks yeah oh that's right
she um she
was she watched that because she was
younger yeah um i think it's you know
you're a dad and you have a family and
you just kind of i i can only speak for
myself she never sees me in the light of
you know my work and so i think i don't
think it's weird for her i just don't
think she's very interested interested
and she's kind of like hey let's go to
the mall or let's talk right now it's
like which you know i love me at mall so
you're in new york for a couple years is
before arrest development and you're
doing i was in there for eight seven
years seven years did you do law and
order are you doing and how did you get
an agent even if if you just you moved
there well i did um it was hard it was
um i i found a commercial agent through
this thing called actors connection
where you pay money to meet agents
and it was like i went like four times
and then i was like oh this is [ __ ]
i've never heard that worked i thought
that was good yeah and then the fifth
time this woman named linda mcintosh
from this agency called s-e-m-m brought
me in
and i just started and i was i was
described as kind of a david schwimmer
type yeah and i was and again like
wide-eyed and kind of checked out i
could that could describe i think
everyone in this room
and so because friends was really
popular yes
and um anyway so i just started going
out for those things and then i did that
for but that was probably a few years
into new york when that happened i had
mainly just doing community way yeah
just off off way off broadway and stuff
and then started doing commercials and
that's and it kind of evened out where
my commercials were able to kind of make
me a living
do you think that gave you a better
perspective in terms of i mean you've
talked about your struggles uh in the
uh
emotion you know in the business and and
um but do you think the fact that you
got into it a little bit later as well
it's kind of the opposite of a child
actor yes
i do and it's
i i had a real appreciation for um i
mean it was hard you know because it was
it was seven or eight years when i had
this commercial agent people could not
see me outside of being a commercial
actor and so it took a long time to find
someone repping me for tv and film and
theater oh seminame was just commercial
just commercials and then finally this
manager
um i met uh
started sending me out and then this
other one i went with
started sending me out
and then the audition for arrested
development came up and the casting
director for that had auditioned for
commercial i think had auditioned
commercials
and so she kind of knew my stuff
um
you started around that time a group
called you founded a group called the
haven yeah are you still a part of it
it's described as an artistically minded
group of christians that met every week
what what was the purpose of that group
and and yeah i mean if i'm selfish i
mean i i am selfish but it's like um i
i moved to new york
my faith has always been very important
to me yeah everything to me and
um i had not met a lot of artists i bet
who yeah who necessarily weren't going a
very you know because very
stereotypical uh faith-based path yeah
everything
you know it was
my the work that i wanted to do was
you know a little different and so it
was just kind of meeting friends that
and who did dance and who yeah
um
who was uh painters and
and maybe it was outside of kind of the
christian way of doing things yeah i i
bet it's hard to find
like-minded people yeah but we it was a
great i just i loved it was a real
support group for me we would also do
we would meet once a week and just kind
of hang out and um
and then we would also do a lot of
service projects
just to kind of uh we would do like a
thanksgiving pie bake we'd make
pies for this one shelter for
thanksgiving and we'd go to this um one
aids hospital for valentine's day all
this but it was a lot of the purpose
just to get our eyes off of ourselves
you know because this business is so
of course you're selling yourself you're
talking about yourself
yeah and you without it you even knowing
it you just are only centered around
yourself i want to ask you a few more
things about yourself um so so arrested
development was the thing that brought
you to l.a
yeah and did you know right away how
soon into that show did you know oh this
is gonna this is gonna change things or
it was a right away uh no it was not
right away because i didn't really have
anything to compare it to yeah i had not
done a string of
other shows where i i was just so happy
to have a gig yeah and i knew i thought
it was funny and i knew that cass
thought it was funny but i didn't really
uh
i was just so and i was also overwhelmed
i had never again
been in that kind of world i'd never
been to those kind of parties yeah i
didn't even know um
just i was just kind of we we just moved
to l.a because ten days before we got
married in new york the show got picked
up so we moved out to l.a wow i'd never
really been to la much yeah so
everything just felt very fresh so i
wasn't really thinking about is this
special but buster is it's it's you're
so brilliant in it you're such a
the show itself is um
i know that word gets thrown around a
lot but i think it really applies to
both this and and veep um but buster the
character you play is
you've talked a lot about anxiety and
yeah struggling with anxiety but he is
like
the epitome
of anxiety was that did uh your the
anxiety that you had just been did that
service like if i was i would not you
would not have seen me play cool job
what i mean buster was obviously taking
the to the extreme but it's like i was
walking around in such an overwhelmed
state and also kind of on the defense
like i didn't know what was coming at me
totally i was like what's around the
corner yeah and so buster always had
this kind of defense mechanism his his
chin would go back and his arms would go
back
mitch hurwitz who created the show said
that all buster ever wanted was safety
and i mean i could i could relate to
that i was like when i say i don't know
what la's like i don't think i
intentionally thought about it that way
if i'm honest i probably should have
done more work with buster but now after
post therapy you have a lot of tools but
back then you just you're feeling all
this overwhelmed feeling and you're just
like to have that outlet to like all
right i can i can put this into the
words i can i can focus on the script i
can focus it this is what i'm gonna do
now and just kind of channel it yeah so
that's what i knew to do i didn't have
all these other tools
[Music]
can you trace any of your own
anxiety your own guilt
you must trace it to childhood but but
what about was it the moving around was
it the
was it
anything to do with christianity was it
anything to do with um i mean i think
it's probably a melting pot of a lot of
different things yeah it's hard it's
hard
to pinpoint um
but i definitely was a through line and
i think with faith
i think there was a season of
expectation like oh as a christian i
should be this way and that's christian
but true faith there's a real freedom
and there's a lot of grace
and the church forgets that especially
in this business
people won't say it but it's it's
actually the undercurrent of like you
will have value when this happens yeah
you will have value when this happens
and the fact is my value as a human
being
has not changed since before i started
this and where i am now and also this is
often a tangent but
the whole idea of fame is interesting
because it's like people look at fame
and they think everybody wants to be
known everybody wants to be seen and
they look at fame as the ultimate being
known but if you really break it down
if you're known by people
you know love you that's all the known
you need because actually the more
famous you get you look at someone who
works at the mall in birmingham alabama
and then you look at someone who's
hugely famous that person is working at
the mall any hello to them any gift they
give any encouragement they give there's
no strings attached right so they feel
known that person is hugely famous all
those things their strings attached of
course so that person that hugely famous
person is actually less known than the
person working in the mall in birmingham
alabama that's true you know i and i
feel that sometimes do you ever ever
when somebody says something nice to you
or or is kind to you and and you you
know that it's not attached to anything
it feels different it does feel
different because there's an
authenticity to there and again all this
is said with both of us are incredibly
grateful to
but i think wherever you know wherever
somebody is in life you know what
we all know an authentic exchange
because it's not even dealing with even
not dealing with the entertainment
industry any anybody who feels like
something wants something from them you
know you can feel the lack of
authenticity transactional yeah you know
as an adult you know i'm not amazing
because you said i'm amazing right right
i know i'm not
but it's also like that just because you
said that doesn't make me amazing that
must be really
really confusing for kids and then when
all that inevitably goes away because it
will i can understand how people
genuinely don't know who they are yeah
you know they don't they really have a
difficult time trying to find their
identity because it's been defined since
they were kids from everybody else which
is why i always really admire
kids actors who were child actors who
were able to overcome that somewhat and
also have a very solid family support
system you know where they could really
teach that them anna klumsky whom you
work with
on this very show about that um
speaking of veep this is i know you love
the show and and you should as you
should uh
do you get tired of talking about it i
don't i was actually thinking on the way
here because like you know we've worked
together a couple times we've been we've
become friends and
if we saw each other more we'd probably
hang out more and it's like and that's
just from having worked sporadically
together right but when you're having
been with these people for almost eight
years it's really uh it's sad that it's
ending like it's just kind of like oh
man like you feel like a part of your
a big part of your journey is kind of
being taken away you know so it's not
just the work i mean i'm so thankful i'm
i think it's funny and i
they work very hard on these scripts and
i love them but it's the relationships
that's yeah ah it's like oh bummer you
you kind of feel like it's never going
to be like that again yeah yeah well
specifically with julia julia louis
dreyfus
i'm going to try to restrain myself
because i i don't want to be weird i'd
love i just mean just be weird the best
this is your opportunity to be true it's
my that's another good name for the show
i goddamn it i can be weird it can be
weird pete holmes already has it but
things got weird that's right
i i to me she did the two of you
together like laurel and hardy level of
comedic symbiosis like how that happened
i don't know is it something that you
it's it's as if you're you're in each
other's heads the way you play off one
another i've seen
moments where
the the connection you have is so
precise and so strong that you're almost
moving together well i think it started
kind of hearing each other's rhythms and
what each other thinks is funny i think
that really helps i think we jived in
that way similar sense of humor yeah
because sometimes you work with people
and you're like i think this is funny
and then you get back i don't think
that's that funny you know it's like
there's not a real there's not a
connection in that part so we both kind
of thought the same things were funny
that goes a long way and that does go a
long way um but it's i think a lot of it
was just we were just we
we just liked each other like we laughed
and
um it reminds me of our um
in the chipmunks thing yeah exactly uh
yeah well there's there's that moment
julie not to make it about all about
julia louie
there's a moment on seinfeld in the
chinese restaurant episode where she
does that she's like i think cherry
betts are like 50 she's like that she
that she can't go over to somebody's
table and eat an egg roll off
the table so when she goes up to them
she goes that guy over there is going to
pay me it's really great uh
that is what like
i
science the seinfeld
the
the combination because i think with
multi-camera comedies it's typically not
seen as subtle
comedy but the way that they were able
to throw jokes away and not have such a
paint by the numbers of like laugh wait
laugh wait because they weren't jokes
yeah you watch those episodes there's so
few real barely any the jokes that are
on the show they often
they're couched as jokes that one of the
characters yeah i don't know how they
did but it was it combined the two
techniques but similarly veep is not a
jokey [ __ ] it's not a joke but you don't
have you have the
beauty of a single camera where it can
you can catch the subtleties you're not
waiting for laugh track all that kind of
stuff anna kalumski or as my mother
calls her anna schlemschke
she uh
she said that it's very
fluid they they there there aren't a lot
of marks there are no you just kind of
capture yeah stuff and there's they're
really uh free with their like if you
missed because i don't know i don't know
if you've been i've i haven't actually
not had this this um situation where
a script is so word to word like it's so
if you miss this if if you miss this the
you're in trouble because it's
definitely on a wrestling v but there
was a lot of freedom to not not make up
a whole new storyline but yeah if you
didn't get it word by word it's
multicams are like that that they really
they're very uh officious about the
scripts um i just did
yeah the connors was like um you said uh
uh i'm sorry instead of oh i'm sorry
really it's that kind of thing and the
only other time i'd had that experience
was doing theater like do you have i'm
gonna talk about anxiety one more time
yeah good
because i haven't done theater in a very
long time and i'm doing it in this
god willing
in san francisco and that's in january
in january okay and it's a one-man play
uh for the most part because there's a
there's a there's some scenes with
somebody else coming in and i'm very
excited about it but it's like managing
that kind of
expectation and anxiety and being like
all right here's yeah these feelings
there they are they're they're not
trying to give them power and
do you ever experience that with theater
my big thing is
people knowing people in the audience i
just don't want to know who's in the
audience oh i don't want to know who's
in the audience absolutely not you know
sam rockwell uh on his when he's doing
plays on his answering machine he'll say
um
hey hey you've reached sam if you're
coming to the play
don't tell me all right don't uh here's
a number for someone who can help you
with the tickets i i don't want to know
when you're coming he's yeah that's
serious about it which i totally can't i
get it it'll totally take you out yeah
yeah absolutely and even when i hear a
laugh of somebody's is it weird that i
feel more nervous now than i did before
i'm sorry you shouldn't you're gonna be
great i'm just kidding uh i'm just
getting cut to getting your kalatapan
and taking my babies
well i can't wait to see it it's in
january in january um in virginia in
virginia why is this funny to me uh i i
don't know
um uh
buster both buster um and gary are
they're in the venn diagram of those two
characters there is some crossover of
course of course
neurosis and emasculated um
what about this character how does this
person this guy's different this guy is
a lot um
speaking of he he's kind of in a place
where it's a lot of existential
questions and thinking about life and
i really i love it's actually asking the
audience a lot of questions yeah i
really
really am looking forward to it the
thing about buster and gary though is um
because there is obviously a lot of
similarities
but i asked that question to
um when i asked mitch like what buster
wanted which is a very actory question
but it helped about safety i look at
gary and he really just wants selena to
love him you know because i don't think
buster as much as he was a mother's boy
he didn't really
i don't think he would jump in front of
the train yeah
but gary would have jumped in front of a
train for celina buster was definitely
more there's something more priv i would
say privilege yeah superseded any of
that yeah totally i love what you said
about his loyalty to to selena um it
stems from the idea that the characters
quote i think you said this is one of
those guys who never really had an
identity he attached himself to people
uh to find who he was yeah and
you must encounter that yes do i all the
time here i mean there's we're in the
city of sycophants uh but i think also
to your point of high school
that's what clicks are it's like
it's attaching themselves to a certain
group or a certain person to give them
an identity to give them strength too i
mean power and validation and dc's like
that who are you attached to yeah does
it and it raises your value yeah that
kind of stuff like agents attaching
themselves to certain actors actors
attaching themselves to certain you know
it's yeah to projects everybody's
looking to attach themselves and even
the word attaches yes who's attached to
that project yeah i'm about to quote
something that i wrote uh but it i i
never say it
when this is all over all that will have
mattered is how and who you love yeah
you know 100 right we've talked about
this a lot here um i just did a play
about it about um the lack of empathy in
sure yeah in the plays it was an
absurdist play and
it's about uh male and female
you know the gender dynamics
and uh i play a guy who was completely
lacking empathy so i've been thinking a
lot more and
because of the cultural sure
sweeping changes that have happened
so in in that case in many of those
cases i i am trying that much harder to
uh have empathy for for where these
people are coming from and it's
something that i don't think i've always
employed and julia actually talked about
that with veep you know selena meyer is
an atrocious
atrocious human being
but the way the reason she can do it so
authentically is because she has to love
this person yeah she's forced to love
her and see
beyond the curt behind the curtain and
see the pain and see
just to find some compassion for her
well and and for gary i mean there's
something yeah there's something
tremendously sad about he's easy to love
because you kind of you want to take
care of him yeah and you bust her a
little bit too
but i remember doing this movie years
ago years ago it was an awful not a good
movie but i was playing kind of a
kind of a douchebag and
and i remember thinking i just don't
like these kind of people and this
diana castle this really wonderful
teacher in l.a i was kind of she was
kind of coaching with her and she says
tony you've got to realize that that's
inside of you all the traits that you
think of this person that you don't like
has been in you yeah and that's when
it's like yeah she's absolutely right
and that's why you get to exercise those
things you get to is that that's when
acting becomes very therapeutic and i
imagine and it's a great way to look at
the world absolutely yeah and uh i've i
max greenfield was on uh oh yeah the
other day i mean he's a nice man the
nice and funny and present and uh god i
really miss talking to him
okay justin i thought this wasn't a
comparison game but oh my god because
why are you sliding a cloth
[Laughter]
you're probably great at improv too i
loved it i love doing it yeah yeah i
don't know how that reminds me of a
scene yeah we did in in this movie
called and then i go
and we were doing you and melanie
linsky's coverage it was a really it was
it was a really you know heavy scene and
powerful and you were bringing your
son and
and it was really a heavy topic i played
the parents of a kid who would later go
and
it was an awful i mean
atrocity it was a very heavy scene and
we were getting your coverage and it was
tony played the principal i was playing
the press but getting great moments from
you and melanie and
the kid
and then they turn around on me and
justin can't stop making jokes to
melanie
and making jokes that's awful i'm sorry
and i was like okay i'm so sorry
that's terrible that's not even funny
i'm sorry tony did i really do that i'm
sorry of course you did but it was very
funny that kid
he was good he was so good and he
thought you were very funny he did i
mean part of it was like i had to keep
up you know he was the star he was the
star uh so he and it was a heavy scene
and you were trying to help the
environment no no but that's but i mean
that was some good memories all right
sorry
um these are really quick uh questions
if you don't mind no please um
what do you think the meaning of life is
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to oh okay oh good
question um it would be uh that face
where the mouth is doing this oh yeah
somebody else had that i don't know how
to describe it but it's all it's like an
awkward face like i don't know what to
do you mean it's just where it's flat
yes like i'm uncomfortable like i'll say
like i think i should try this oh all
right because it's kind of like i don't
know i don't know yeah yeah like hedging
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense uh
i can just see you saying your bubble
says should i do justin's podcast
oh
she wants me to be back on yeah push you
to do it and then another emoji two of
them
crying emoji devil face turd
um
your favorite movie of all time
it's a tie
between tale of desperate tale
desperate pre-casting
um uh it's a
lars on the real girl
or uh punch drunk glove
oh i love that those are the two that's
great
come to me because i think interesting i
especially lars and the real girl
on the log line of a man having a
blow-up doll
it was the movie was so about the power
of community and how we're not meant to
be alone and we're meant to have people
around us and
and also just the compassion the town
had for him when the doll he had to put
the doll away yeah it's really a
beautiful message of just community do
you are you a
guide guide
i don't i don't do pot i um i molly i
don't chest molly i just do molly yeah
um i've never really i don't know if
it's because i had asthma i never really
did pot as a kid and i think the fact
that i just said i don't do pot yeah
so we should cut all this but i did
but i did try um
uh cbd
yeah and it helps me i have trouble
sleeping sometimes so it helps me sleep
me too a lot of uh
crossover could be talking myself um
almost done uh who's your favorite
muppet um my favorite muppet i'm glad
you asked that because i have two ah
um can i guess yes uh
beaker yes you're lying no you you look
this up look it up where where is this
one of them because he's my face yeah
because he his non-verbal was so funny
to me yes and he
he's that's what archibald is that shape
oh yeah and um
it reminded me of beaker uh-huh and he's
uh an archibald's yellow because that's
my favorite color but beaker had this
like
kind of tube-like shape yeah and would
just hit his chin would go back yes i
love the way his mouth moved and he was
just like
and then my other one is because i
always had a stuffed animal of him his
scooter
oh yeah scooter's great i had little
glasses and he kind of was a little
nerdy and yeah probably i resonated with
him of like being a nerd see both of
those in you uh
if you could have either super x-ray
vision or super hearing which would you
choose
um super x-ray or super hearing i'd
probably
do vision because i already hear too
much like i'm the guy in the restaurant
where i i have a hard time focusing
because i know the person next to me is
breaking up and then the other person is
like it's a first date like i can't
it's already too much noise you know
melanie linsky did she tell you about
this has misophonia
did you know that i don't know what that
is it's the the um it's when mouth
sounds are really
upsetting to you uh to the point where
she could pinpo she could pick it out a
mouth sound out that was upsetting her
from like
30 feet away from like across a
restaurant like like just like eating
somebody eating like oh yeah well i mean
nothing is worse than eating a crust
when somebody in their mouth is open
while they're eating yeah
yeah you're just like i don't we don't
want to see any of that yeah yeah
beetles stones
uh beetles my daughter just did a play
where they sang beetle songs oh how
great it was nothing cuter than that
she's saying nowhere man
what would you want your uh your epitaph
to read
um
uh
uh
and that's all written out with ellipses
i would say
this is my hope that he loved god and he
loved others
um i love you
uh
i as much as i love god and that it's
gonna be okay uh you know what i'd love
to hear is it's gonna be okay yeah i
don't think we say that to enough each
other and actually there's a line in toy
story where forkie goes everything's
going to be okay and it's just like
ugh it's so nice to hear that's really
nice to hear it is nice to hear um every
this has been so nice it has been it's
gone by fast i know but it was easy
because and i feel this way every time i
hang out with you and we should do it
publicly more
i don't know
our conversations can only be on camera
or taped
but uh everyone please watch tony in the
last uh season of vp uh it was a couple
weeks ago with the season finale and um
already are you guys
is the separation anxiety begun
with the camera we typically don't shoot
until the falls i think when the fall
comes around is when it's going to hit
us okay and that's when i'll just go
into a corner and cry and and then you
do a play and then i do a play and i
work on it and then i work and i channel
it well we can't wait to see that that's
at act in january in san francisco and
archibald's coming out in the fall okay
and i'm sure we'll be on a game show
together oh wouldn't that be fine i hope
and just destroy people you know we can
play games together uh off camera i
don't know okay
again it wouldn't have it wouldn't be
real if it wasn't yes it wasn't
documented that's true we should start
recording this by the way
um thanks buddy
well
that
has just happened oh yeah that just
happened
i already forgot the catchphrase
um that happened and man i
listening to it back i made me miss
when it was happening um i just he's
he's the best you know it was a really
good
life is short show uh-huh because it was
funny it was light most of the time but
there was some real life and death chat
yeah some dark stuff you know i love my
death chat oh you sure do um you're a
sucker it was it was light and deep
did it it
that's good yeah he is and he um
navigates between the two really
effortlessly you know he's not and he's
just so earnest he's such a sincere
person he's really thoughtful there i
was struck by a couple times he said you
know on my way here i was thinking about
you know
he put thought into the interview before
he was interviewed yeah and that struck
me as well he this guy is
really thoughtful yeah you know i know
it was it kind of like moved me a little
bit that he was took it seriously
yeah yeah that's really nice uh he talks
about he talks a lot about his struggles
with anxiety and
i i i
thought it was so great how he talked
you know you you were talking about
legacy and
and uh
what kind of matters to him and if and
and if he thinks the work he's doing um
is important yeah i guess
he remembered
but he said it's not really about that
it's he he tries to make
the on-set experience as positive as
possible and he tries to be kind and
open and to him and i really believe
that when he says this
that's so much more important than any
sort of legacy that he's leaving behind
which
he's leaving behind yeah
quite a legacy too yeah
yeah like classic we were comparing him
to the marx brothers in laurel and
hardin and i don't think that's
hyperbole i really do think he is
comedically on that level i do too and
and i
i so admire the way he sees legacy i i
think i i aspire to see it that way
myself i think i do i mean i i certainly
do i think that way a lot more so than i
used to um
now to me it really is about the the
process and and the people that you're
working with and uh
but i i it
it sounds like it could be [ __ ] you
know if you just read him saying that
yeah that's the nice thing about a
podcast you can hear it in his voice you
can hear his sincerity and i i can
personally attest the fact that he
comports himself like that on set
that's a good word uh you guys talked
about how
you don't see each other that frequently
but when you do you really get along and
he said something like you know if i if
i saw more of you we we would be closer
friends you know it's just kind of a
matter of
um circumstances
he's got a family it's true um
but i i that made perfect sense to me
because you two seemed like
you would be really good friends you
have a lot in common um
among them is he loves and he's never
really gotten over getting a free lunch
on set he talks about that and i know
you're someone who
loves a freelancer oh yeah uh he talks
about getting the free long distance
calls when he did the temp job
uh i used to do that
you're both cheap and that's what you
have in
common well but that's it but it struck
me yeah
that's such a common that's such a
perfect crossover between you two yeah
you know what's funny i um the last job
i did was this
i think i've talked about a little bit
it's coming out in november this hosting
shop for this disney plus show and um it
was a little bit like i never hosted a
thing like that before and so it took a
little bit of like creative adjustment
but it turned out to be so fun um
but the the catering that they used was
so good it was small it was a small
production but um this company and i was
so every day i'd we'd go on and the crew
was like yeah we get it it's good isn't
this amazing look what they have today
and i i couldn't get over what kind of
stuff oh man they had and they had all
these delicious vegan options which i'm
not vegan but i was like oh man if i if
this is what all vegan food tastes like
i could probably do this um
just inventive uh even when they made
like a chicken breast thing it was like
really well done tender and the whole
thing was just so all like organic
grass-fed blah blah you know well it was
disney yeah no i guess they had the
money for it so but i was like i
couldn't get over it i kept hoarding
little snacks to bring home uh the kid
driving me was 21. he kept making fun of
me he's like don't aren't they paying
you for this yeah i was like squirreling
away little doritos bags and stuff
that's a very tony hail move
yeah i love that about him and it's
funny because every time i see him on
one of these things like you know we
talk about doing this the like game show
circuit
whenever i leave hanging out with them
i'm always like why uh why don't we hang
out also more than anything that
connects you is the fact that you're
both david schwimmer types
yeah yeah and i can say that because i'm
a david schwemmert too and that's not a
bad thing to be no no i i
you know it's funny i get either david
schwimmer or keanu reeves and i'm always
so and this is no offense to schwimmer
i'm so flattered when i get it's more
just about how much i love keanu reeves
i'm so flattered by that which and i and
then i thought like well keanu reeves
maybe occasionally i wonder if he ever
gets
me
that's arrogant of me to think no i bet
it happens not that people are like oh
not that they mistake him for me but
that they're like hey has everyone
anyone ever told you you look like that
guy
see i think it's more likely that they
don't know
who he is first like no one says to
keanu reeves knowing these counters you
remind me of now justin not even his
enemies
but a few enemies if people don't know
it's him and he's on the subway
uh being anonymous as he does which is
amazing i've heard that maybe is that
just lore uh
no
apparently he apparently takes the
subway gives a lot of money to charity
gives almost all his money away he
sounds like an incredible person goals
person calls or maybe he just has a
great publicist who's created that story
oh that's so cynical but um but yeah
schwimmer we get a lot yeah tony
mentioned schwimmer schwimmer i think
people always say it like it's a bad
thing like it's all right they couch it
like i uh of the friends of the male
friends i would
maybe just because maybe just because i
do i'd want to look like david schumer
the most i think really yeah well now
yeah now yeah that's what i mean oh okay
[Laughter]
okay this is a slippery slide yeah
um he he has which we didn't mention in
the beginning uh he has
a show that's i believe out now it is on
netflix archibald
yes it's a cartoon
yeah it's really sweet of he's been
posting it on instagram um archibald is
a chicken and it's about um a very
positive open uh
empath empathetic started off as a
children's book and now it's uh become a
show an animated show on netflix uh tony
created the show and from what i know of
him it's the perfect
uh idea for a children's show for him to
have come up with it's about a chicken
who
is very present and um
and he talks about that being something
that he's had to work on yeah in his
life being more present yeah i think
it's something that we all have to work
on
uh especially
these days with phones and stuff it's
i struggle i know tremendously being
present but i think it's a really
positive
uh thing to put out there for him yeah
for for kids for the world for adults
too yeah it's you know do you get those
every week do you get those uh updates
on i get them sunday morning where it's
like you've spent
this many hours on your phone no this
past week i think for whatever reason
mine isn't turned on and i don't know
how to turn around and i'm kind of glad
about i'm happy that way it's really
depressing
i love his swim team story do you
remember that when he said uh
when we were talking about sports and
his dad his dad tells a story where he
tony was in a swim he had some swim meet
and he was like halfway through the race
and he just stopped
because because the pool was shallow
enough so he could just stop and stand
up in the pool and he just said uh i'm
exhausted why would i keep going
isn't it funny to imagine tony as a
teenager is so funny yeah because when
you think about it there is something
there's something kind of absurd about
the whole idea of a race of a swim race
you know
it's like jerry seinfeld has that really
funny uh bit about the horse racing when
when they the horses get to the end of
the race and they're like
out of breath and they're like
what what was the point of that
why did we just do that we're right back
where we started
it's true though there's something he's
saying there's something absurd about it
that's so funny i can picture jay
because jerry also has like
not an insult he's got like but it could
sounds like one he's got kind of a horse
horsey sort of face and when he's making
that like
oh god
that was so funny it's so it's so true i
think that's sometimes when i'm rooting
for sports you know when i'm rooting for
but like football season started which
i'm really excited about but i've been
like yeah like
so when we see sports fans in like
stadiums and i went with with my friend
taryn recently to a rams game and like
taran gets so into it and it's funny to
me because it's like he exposes the
absurdity of like
really caring that much and taryn's not
that kind of guy but i think part of it
is i think he kind of takes a delight in
the absurdity of it it's insane it's
insane but i'm we're both guilty of it
yeah oh my god we both get emote we care
since we were little kids we've gotten
emotionally invested
really like upset over things uh
about sports i hate people we've never
met never met never will me probably i
hate to book end this uh this episode
with like me being a
like a little tantrum-y kid but i i
remember throwing like full-on tantrums
when the the rams for some i like the
l.a right we grew up in connecticut but
i like the la rams because they go why
because they had cool uniforms i loved
the outfits did i like the colors
and there was one player named eric
dickerson who had like really a cool
helmet and like goggles goggles yeah he
was cool he's awesome to look at yeah
he's a great looking guy
along came tom brady and i switched
allegiances but i i remember when they
played the bears in the 1986 i think
championship
and the rams had been having a great
season they played the bears which was
damien's favorite team even though he
wasn't really that into football or our
older brother and they got blown out i
mean they got destroyed and i was
apoplectic i was so angry you were a
little tantrum-y kid yeah god sorry
weird i well no
you just have to spend more time with
tony hale yeah that's he'll rub off on
it his positivity will rub off i wish
i'd known him when i was a kid one of
my biggest takeaways from this whole
thing was that was how he gives
christianity a really good name yes and
i think
we we grew up christian and and it's
something i think we both struggle with
and
obviously in the news
it's it's not in such a great place and
you're constantly hearing negative
things about it
but
i think it's very easy to forget that
regardless of how it's been uh abused
and and um
kind of portrayed and bastardized over
the years at its essence
it like the things that jesus says are
it's really difficult to argue right you
know and how good how they can only lead
to good and i think if applied properly
and his his talking about it is a good
reminder of that because totally he was
saying you know i just i want to do he
does service projects and he thinks of
other people so all these things that
that
he sort of applies to it is seems to be
to me
um
kind of at its core what it's supposed
to be about you're saying he's like
jesus christ yeah he's christ like he's
christ but he he is you know in the
sense that like he is the
a perfect
if you apply all of those tenets those
fundamental tenets of christianity to a
person he kind of embodies that
it's supposed to be simple i think you
know if you're if you just follow the
teachings right it should be simple
right that's gotten really treat other
people with respect and you know take
care of the less fortunate and do unto
others i mean all of that stuff is it
seems like
and his faith is clearly very important
to him
that
to me it seems like he is doing it the
best way possible yeah you know the the
the way it's supposed to be done totally
he's he is a good a representation of
that i also have to we grew up with my
godfather uh my dad's our dad's our paws
friend uh his name was joan noble father
joe he was a missionary he did a lot of
work in new guinea and um he was just
one of the most selfless giving
people like wonderful he was like
he was heroic to me at the time because
he was also a big guy and he had played
football handsome very happy very
handsome and and really sacrificed his
whole life he died at a young age but
he was uh a very strong example for us
growing up about the good that um
catholicism can do and and now i work
with a group in nicaragua it's a home
for girls called the girls home which i
may have mentioned on the show
you can check it out at
www.thegirlshome.com um but it's run by
a group of nuns about
catholic nuns and
you will not meet
people who are
more selfless and devoted to giving to
others it's a nice reminder you know
because i think like i said that the
negative aspects of it and the
corruption of the whole institution i
think has taken uh front page headlines
for a while and you lose sight of the
assassins well thanks tony for that uh
and finally i
i um i like that he is he didn't waver
at all when it when it came to the short
answers to answering those uh questions
at the end um that's right and and to me
that that is yet another example of
how thoughtful he is that he's not that
he's thought about those specific
questions but
he's thought a lot about things in
general i think that so he has he can
access things like that pretty easily
you know yeah
favorite movie favorite this favorite
that favorite um you know uh muppet oh
that was a great answer perfect answer
yeah speak here
he is such a
he's such a clown it just seems like i
mean maybe to his detriment that he you
know he talks about his anxiety and i
think people who
are that thoughtful and overthinking
yeah it tends to make them spiral a
little bit and so it may
it may not always be a positive thing
for him but he's humble enough to admit
that he's a work in progress like he
said yeah he's yeah he has a long way to
go it doesn't to me it doesn't seem like
he has a long way to go but
it's like he's pretty much there yeah
but i'm sure he does you know but that's
humility that's like i mean it would be
it wouldn't be christ-like yeah it
wouldn't be christ like or tony hale
like to be like i'm pretty good i'm i'm
there i'm i'm involved uh i get it
because we're all a work in progress
what a good man yeah yeah so thank
thanks to him and thank you guys for
listening we have
a letter go uh letter and i've not been
reading these um which may be clear i
mean i've not been reading them
beforehand so christian is going to hand
me
my baby just wrote me a letter oh god
sorry give me a dick everybody i don't
blame you
uh
this letter is from baby just wrote me
an email uh tina i
to protect her anna oh yeah okay tina i
this is from tina eye
uh subject is how i make the most how i
make most of life
she is finished give her a break right
um well wait till i finish it
oh sorry wishing well for other i'm not
going to do the finnish accent i respect
the tina please don't all the listeners
you've already ruined canada
that's true
um
wishing well for others and enjoying
their success in the core of our i'm
going to start again wishing well for
others and enjoying their success and in
the core of your being is good for you
no need to feel guilty for hitching on
the happy ride i am so proud of my
family and friends for their
achievements in traditional ways such as
studies and careers hobbies and
experiences like traveling but also i'm
so happy to see them behave so kindly
and with empathy also i enjoy strangers
doing well and this may be limited to
what i consider as doing well but still
i feel like good things in the world
make the world in general better i
really like that you know that's very
tony hale of tina
tony and tina
someone someone doing things that hurt
themselves or others is not good news to
me no matter how well it is promoted
your friend got the job you applied for
good for them they worked hard as you
did and they will be good in the
position and you will find your place
happy posts on instagram rather than
feeling jealous or wondering how much of
them are staged or gossiping about the
real story i just hope for the best for
everyone and add the good news to my
good mood very tony hale i get the irony
of suffering from chronic depression as
an optimist but actually those things
tend to go together more than we would
think because depression is often about
caring about what happens to people in
the world and seeing the bad realities
but we can still be counting the good
things and appreciating the changes for
better maybe even more
thanks for reading i love the podcast
tina that's so nice and and actually
that's exactly that's very tony hawk
very tony hill
um that she suffers from depression uh
while still having this very positive
empathetic outlook it's really unfair it
just struck me that it's it
it's really unfair that people who are
empathetic
towards other people into the world and
to other people's suffering
uh
would like that could potentially lead
to depression whereas
whereas someone who only thinks about
themselves and is you know
yeah
just but it's all about them they
probably wouldn't get depressed because
they only have to worry about one thing
yeah and like what else is going to get
them down yeah as long as you're
successful if you're like right i'm
trying to think of an example i mean we
probably shouldn't mention it like
blindly unaware of the like pain and
suffering of others is like you know
when they say ignorance is bliss it's
like well that that there is probably
some kind of bliss
it's not you're right yeah anyway anyway
life is short
um but
let's let's dwell on the goodness and
and if tina's letter um and tony's uh
interview tells us anything it's to to
really like uh embrace the good parts of
life too and
and that's hard it's easier said than
done thank you tina for writing in and
if you guys want to write in we would
love to hear from you
uh it's life is short at wondery.com
so that's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
mieshlands
and it is
audio engineered by the one and only
marcelino viapando
and it is executive produced
by marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
thank you
bye
[Music]
getting an ice cream truck as an adult i
feel like
i think i might feel
i feel like you're weird disgusting or
something yeah or uh but i feel like a
deviant i mean it's like swimming in a
kiddie pool yeah yeah imagine we're like
going like a in a bubble pop house you
know like one of those like bouncy
houses but see at least that
uh there's something that physically
doesn't make sense about that three
words too big for that we're too big for
a kiddie pool we're too big for a bounce
house yeah but adults don't buy ice
cream ice cream drop that's true but
it's still weird i was still just as
weird as being in a kiddie pool i think
to me
yeah i would look down on an adult at an
ice cream truck especially if you were
in a line with just kids well you'd look
like a parent and if somebody was like
you look like a parent
those are the only two people that can
go to adults thing go to ice cream
trucks parents are perfect that's funny
it'd be funny if that wasn't an ice
cream truck now it's just like a nerd
practice it might be yeah outside an ice
cream truck or a nerd practicing a like
a liar
[Laughter]
i don't think i've ever heard anyone
reference a liar in out loud is that is
that a flute a type of flute so
a liar i've always seen it in prince i
think i don't think i've ever heard that
a liar might be a stringed instrument a
liar yeah it might be like a band like a
mandolin yeah i think it is like this
maybe it's a loot
what's a loot
a loot sounds like flute more of a
mandolin
yeah maybe a liar is a flute can you
look at the difference
you